- Les urgences des hôpitaux
débordent. Une crise sans
précédent yeyeyeux du médecin
hygiéniste en chef.- - - - - - s
les Ontariens, pas seulement
les plus vulnérables, portent
le masque à l'intérieur,
dans les endroits publics.sisiss
ont déjà emboîté le pas.
Dr JEROME , , , dir. médical,
Hôpital Sunnybrook
- Dans les der v v v v v v v v s
de masques qu'il y a quelques
semaines auparavant.
Alors, je pense que les gens ont
- Dans un tweet diffusé
dihehehe, le Collège
des médecins du Québec
proposait la mê Une mesure qui e
l'ampleur de la crise vécue
Une mesure qui reflète
l'ampleur de la crise vécue par.
Dr JESSE PAPENBURG
tatatatal de Mtl pour enfants
- C'est une crise parce que nous
avons un tsunami d'infections
- Un tsunami qui force déjà le
report de certaines chirur
- On fait déjà du délestage.
J'ai des chirurgies querererere.
- Il appuie donc l'obligation de
porter le masque à l'intérieur
dans les lieux publics. Mais
l'idée rebute bien des citoyens.
- C'est bon là. Il y anananananc
je pense qu'on a assez supporté
les masques.
tente plus, puis la majorité
le porte pas, ça fait que moi
non plus, puis je pense
c'est correct.
- La santé publique
le ministère de la Santé
du Québec se contentent
des citoyens. À l'évidence,
personne ne mbmbmbmbmballé
par l'idée d'imposer à nouveau
le port du masque.
Radio-Canada, Montréa